do you think about
expert systems is there um and
why they kind of didn't
become successful especially in the
space of bioinformatics
where it does seem like there's a lot of
expertise in humans
and uh you know it's it's possible to
see that
a system like this could be made very
useful
right so it's it's actually it's a it's
a great question and and this is
something so you know so
uh you know at my university i teach
artificial intelligence and you know we
start the my first two lectures are on
the history of ai
and and there we you know we tried to
you know go through the main stages of
ei and so you know the question of why
expert systems failed
or became obsolete it's actually a very
interesting one and there are you know
if you
uh try to read the you know the
historical perspectives there are
actually
two lines of thoughts one is that the
they were uh essentially
not up to the expectations and so
therefore
they were replaced you know uh by by
other
things right the other one
was that uh completely opposite one that
they were
too good and and as a result
they essentially became sort of a
household name and
then essentially they they got
transformed
i mean they in both cases sort of the
outcome was the same they evolved into
something
yeah right and that's what i you know if
if i look at this right so the modern
machine learning
right so those echoes in in the modern
i think that's all i think so because
you know if if you think about this you
know and how we design
uh you know uh the most successful
algorithms including alpha fault right
you built in the knowledge about the
domain
that you study right so you build in
your expertise
you